- C'est ici, dans cette
résidenc a a a a a a a a a a a s
de demandeurs d'asile chaque
mois. Depuis le début
de l'année, près de 30 000
persle chemin Roxham. Les centrs
d'hébergement débordent.
À tel point que les refuges
pour sans-abri sont sollicités.
générale, Refuge des jeunes
- Avant la pandémie,
on accueillait 600 jeunes
dans une année. Et maintenant,
probablement autour de 500
et de ce nombre, 10 % so
des jeunes qui vont demander
l'asile.
reçoit chaque nuit jusqu'à
sososososonnes. Des sans-abri
de 17 à 26 ans, de plus en plus
d'asile.- - - - - On a de plus s
qui sont laissés à eux-mêmes,
d'assurance-maladie, sans rien
et qui se retrouvent, donc,
stationnés dans un refuge
et sans porte de sortie.
- Ce jeune homme, qui préfère
garder l'anonymat, l'a vécu.
Originaire de l'Angola, il est n
Roxham quelques semaines avant
sa mère et sa soeur.
"Il nous a appelé un soir,
ra
qu'il n'avait nulle part
où aller, il a finalement dormi
dans un McDonald."
ARTHUR DURIEUX, gestionnaire,
centre Le Pont
- C'est des histoires qui sont
rares, mais qui commencent
- C'est finalement Arthur qui
a accueilli la i i i i ici.
Le centre Le Pont est
un hébergement d'urgence
J'imagine qui a des gens
que ezezezezez refuser?
- À tous les jours. Il y a
des personnes qui nous
une chambre puis je dois d d d .
- Ce sont surtout des femmes et
des familles qui habitent ici.
des personnes qui n'arrivent
pas à se loger autrement.
C'est le cas de Martha.
avec son mari et ses deux
filles en juin. Ils ont
obtenu une chambre au YMCA,
qui n'est que temporaire.
"On ne deesesesesester qu'une
semaine", explique-t-elle.
"Il fallait quitter rapidement
puisqu'il y avait du roulement
au
... On ressentait beaucoup
de pression, mais c'était
appartement. Les prix étaient
trop élevés."
Des propriétaires lui
ont demandé jusqu'à sr.r.r.r.r..
Au bout de trois semaines,
ils ont finalement atterri
eux aussi au centre Le Pont.
Ils sont, tos s s s s s s s s s.
- Par exemple, j'ai une famille
avec quatre très jeunes enfants,
des bébés de 6 mois, 4 ans,
8 anet les deux parents ont dori
dehors pendant plusieurs jours
parce qu'ils savent pas où
aller et tous les centres
en ce moment.
- Dans ceux qu'on accueill
il y en a qui ont fait un
j'ai des jeunes qui soésésésésés
ici quelques mois.tttttttttttttt
souvent un permis ililililil qui
leur permet de payer un loyer,'r
ont explosé.
- Moi, je pense quelàlàlàlàlàlàt
à un dididididigne et humain.
Qu'on puisse l'offrir au
re
mais qu'est-ce qui va arriver
p p p p prochaines années?
- Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,